philosophie est tel aviv alors je vais
présenter nos deux invités
luc ferry et frédéric schiffter luc
ferry présentation vous avez 55 ans vous
êtes fils d'ouvrier mécanicien oui mon
père faisait des voitures de course
voilà l'été pilote de course auto qui
n'était lens que vous voyez mécaniciens
et on vous connaît également pu faites
ce que vous a été entre 2002 et 2004
ministre de la jeunesse de l'éducation
et de la recherche du gouvernement
raffarin
frédéric schiffter vous avez 50 ans vous
êtes professeur de philosophie à
biarritz et à aristote kanté sarthe ont
dit vous préférez montaigne gainsbourg
et welbeck
parce que oui j'ai voulu te souhaite un
peu raccourcie mais n'en va pas fort non
plus alors vos ouvrages luc ferry
apprendre apprendre à vivre traité de
philosophie à l'usagé des jeunes
générations
alors effectivement ce livre est un
texte qui s'adresse un peu le filtre
c'est comme la philosophie raconter aux
enfants et à leurs parents un traité
dont vous voulez qu'ils aillent à
l'essentiel sans être superficiel quand
j'ai lu votre livre sentiment que c'est
un livre qui répondent toujours à la
même question celle du salut à travers
différentes époques
frédéric schiffter votre ouvrage donc
philosophe sans qualité qui est paru aux
éditions flammarion est un ouvrage qui
on va dire une autobiographie
philosophique et dans votre ouvrage et a
beaucoup d'humour et à un certain goût
de la formule et une vision assez
désespérée de la vie vous direz vous
dirai ce qu'il en est on à l'impression
quand on a lu votre livre que la
philosophie ne vaut rien mais que rien
ne vaut la philosophie alors première
question toute bête pour vous la
définition de la philosophie
moi je suis très frappé par une chose
même en vieillissant c'est que chez les
premiers philosophes chez les grecs
on a cette idée qu'on ne peut bien vivre
on peut vraiment être être heureux mais
bien vis un peu autre chose d'être
heureux que si on a réussi à vaincre ses
peurs et puis il ya une peur fondamental
à mes yeux qui est la matrice de toutes
les autres qui est évidemment la peur de
la mort mais pas forcément la peur de la
sienne souvent on est plus préoccupé par
la mort des autres d'ailleurs la
première phrase de votre livre c'est la
mort de votre père vient phrase la
première page de livre ce qui me paraît
aussi de très significatif et est donc
j'ai été très frappée en lisant les
premiers philosophes de voir que leurs
questions fondamentales au fond c'est la
question de montaigne philosopher c'est
apprendre à mourir non pas du tout par
délectation morose ou par passion des
questions morbide mais parce qu'on ne
peut pas revenir à bien vivre que si on
a réussi à surmonter cette peur est donc
ce que je donne comme définition de la
philosophie très simplement
c'est une doctrine du salut je pense
comme les religions sauf que les
religions à nous promettre qu'on va être
sauvée de cette peur de la mort ou de la
mort elle-même grâce à un autre par un
autre qui est dieu avec un grand d alors
que la philosophie et last espèces
d'orgueil fust espèce d'arrogance
initiale que d'ailleurs tous les grands
penseurs religieux chrétiens notamment
vont me reprocher saint-augustin pascal
déteste ça chez les philosophes cette
espèce d'arrogance qui consiste à dire
on va vaincre la peur par soi même c'est
reparle l'exercice de sa propre raison
c'est bien ça que qui m'ennuie un peu
avec la
la philosophie c'est justement cette
cette prétention c'est à dire que
oui il ya deux sortes de pensées
concurrentes rival comme vous l'avait
dit il ya la religion qui propose un
salut qui viendrait de l'extérieur qui
serait un salut venant de la
transcendance et il y aurait à salluit
maintenant qu'ils viendraient de soi
même comme si nous étions les mille les
mieux placés nous les pauvres mortels
pour nous nous nous préserver de ces de
cette peur fondamentale qui est celle de
la mort et ce qu'ils méritent un peu
dans le dans certains systèmes
philosophiques c'est qu'il tente de
rivaliser avec la religion et finalement
il me semble que lui aurait peut-être
plus de profits pour les gens à s'en
remettre en effet à des églises ou à des
sectes
il trouverait davantage leurs profits
pour se consoler de l'idée qu'ils vont
mourir ou delà de la frayeur qu'ils vont
mourir plutôt que dans ceux de s'en
remettre aux philosophes qui offre aux
vocations sont bien sont bien compliqué
pour
pour ça ce qui m'intéresse justement
dans la philosophie c'est de voir à quel
point cette cette forme de pensée qui
qui qui se veut décalée par rapport à
l'opinion courante et d'une façon
générale qui serait une pensée lucide
c'est qui ce qui m'amuse c'est de voir à
quel point la philosophie reconduit en
son sein de grandes illusions qui ferait
de nous des gens souverain de notre
destin de notre vie et c'est alors que
comme disait fédéral la vie est un
processus de démolition le et aura
d'autres services et de hasard adieu
adieu les beaux projets alors si vous
prenez les grands démolisseurs
d'illusions par exemple prenons
nietzsche il ya quand même une idée qui
va reprendre aussi bien aux épicuriens
costaud haïtiens à spinoza qui va
traverser toute l'histoire la
philosophie c'est que il ya deux mots
qui pèse sur l'existence humaine il y a
deux fatalités qu'ils sont nous empêche
de vivre c'est comment dire le poids du
passé qu'on vit dans la nostalgie du
passé des paradis perdu et ensuite il ya
une autre fatalité une autre catastrophe
qui pèse sur nous c'est l'espérance d'un
avenir meilleur
et l'idée que dans le futur ça va aller
mieux et nous passons notre vie entière
à imaginer que d'abord est dans le
projet ce qui est idiot ou mon avis en
tout cas et à imaginer que en achetant
une voiture une maison en changeant de
métiers de femmes de maris on va être
plus heureux dans ces deux mots qui nous
culpabiliser sans arrêt nous empêche de
vivre le présent qui est au fond la
seule chose qui vaille est la seule
chose qui existe vraiment un mot sur sur
l'idée que l'on pourrait
vaincre d'un côté le nostalgique et de
l'autre côté l'espoir on espère pouvoir
se débarrasser de l'espoir on espère
pouvoir se débarrasser de la crainte
mais mais mais justement et on finit par
peut-être pas reprendre son désirs pour
la réalité et donc reconduire une
illusion
la même on croit la détruire cette
philosophie qui nous propose à agir
n'est ce pas qu'ils me proposent d'agir
dans le sens d'un oubli du passé comme
du futur
à mon avis c'est une philosophie du oui
de l'est encore de l'espérance c'est une
fête une emprise possible aucune emprise
possible je ne crois pas la philosophie
même chez spinoza même chez nietzsche
même chez epicure même chez les plus
grands pourfendeurs de l'illusion même
chez ceux qui ont vraiment bu le vin
jusqu'à la lie ceux qui ont vraiment
compris ce que ça voulait dire que dieu
était mort ou ce que je voulais pointé
c'est le fait que même ces philosophies
là elles sont même les plus des
constructrice elles sont quand même des
doctrines du salut ce qui est génial
dans la philosophie c'est que même si on
fait pas on se dit bien on veut pas dire
ah bon je vais lire la philosophie pour
après être heureux et plus libre c'est
pas comme ça mais ce que quiconque le
lira les très grands philosophie
trouvera quand même c'est au moins
l'explicitation avec lui même de tout ce
qu'ils pensent de plus profond de votre
choix explicite et c'est déjà ça c'est
une france de libération vous est
d'accord c'est sur ce plan c'est pour
moi peut-être la libération
maximum et de la philosophie ne nous
apprend pas à vivre là nous apprend à
lire on a des éclaireurs on a des idées
des gens qui voient là qui nous
permettent d'accéder à ce qui est me
semble-t-il le trésor de la philosophie
à ce niveau là simplement c'est c'est la
lucidité mais quand elle est clair
l'homme quand elle essaie d'éclairer
l'homme et quand elle essaye de montrer
justement où va se nicher où vont se
nicher toutes ses illusions et je pense
que cette lucidité d'avoir n'est pas
hors de la vie c'est un lire ça n'est
pas hors de la ville s'est pas l'action
mais sépare de la vie où c'est une autre
forme d'action et ensuite je crois que
ces grandes visions du monde
philosophique ou ses grandes
constructions philosophie peu importe
comme on les appelle l éclair un certain
nombre de partis pris parce que en gros
nous sommes dans des partis pris on peut
tout ça il ya des gens qui sont toujours
dans la nostalgie ou toujours dans
l'espérance d'autres qui sont dans la
légèreté dans l'insouciance
vous avez des particules est vraiment le
génie à l'état pur je n'ai que des par
marc et je n'ai que des partis pris et
celle de justifier une autre et quand
même que depuis au moins une bonne
décennie en france
les livres de philosophie qui se vendent
le mieux ce sont des philosophies qui
nous invite à des formes de vie vélo il
ya le volet dit que la philosophie est
passé aux rayons du bien-être oui je
crois que la philosophie propose des
recettes d'existence des recettes de
bonheur des recettes
alors du coup on ne sait plus très bien
où elle se situe dans la psychologie
dans le dans le kerry dans la recette de
bon alors ce qu'elle en est là à la
philosophie
moi je verrais dans la philosophie
plutôt comment dire une interprétation
laïque au faux non religieuses on va
parler simplement de la religion grecque
c'est à dire que dans la religion
grecque vous avez des entités je pars
ouranos le ciel gardien la terre vous
avez toute une série de dieu qui
représentent des éléments
et puis au bout d'un moment dieu ce le
chef des dieux si je puis dire c'est la
guerre contre les titans qu'il a gagné
il finit par faire un partage
et puis mais chaque chose à sa place et
c'est comme ça que l'idée de cosmos
apparaît elle était justement que tout
est ordonné parce qu'après cette espèce
de chaos qui a été la guerre entre les
dieux et titan et bien eu ça réussit à
mettre chacun à sa place est au fond ce
qu'ils proposent aux hommes c'est de
s'accorder à cet ordre du monde bien
supérieurs à eux et dans lequel il les
invite à entrer donc moi je vois plutôt
dans la naissance de la philosophie
quelque chose assez joyeux qui est une
sécularisation de la religion grecque
il y à des philosophes qui
obsédé par la cohérence la cohésion de
leur système
bon et bien on oublie peut-être le
travail d'écrivain
alors il faut que ça colle il faut que
ça rentre veut que le poste de toutes
les pièces du puzzle soient
véritablement agencé de telle sorte que
ça donne une image effectivement de
cohérence absolue
et alors là c'est le philosophe se prend
pour dieu erguy surplombe le monde et
après il dit voilà moi le monde il est
comme ça et je vous le donne et et puis
à le penseur qui
et plutôt dans le fragment qui justement
qu'il y prend des pièces du chaos sans
essayer de du puzzle sont essayé d'en
faire un justement et je m'en tiendrai à
cette formule 2 / an que je trouve
excellente avait très vache on enfin
elle est excellente il dit les
philosophes écrivent pour les
professeurs et les penseurs pour les
écrivains
voilà je trouve que là c'est imparable
alors au terme de ce débat je vais vous
demander une phrase ça va être un
exercice extrêmement difficile j'en ai
bien conscience et revenir sur notre sur
notre thème la philosophie est elle à
vivre luc ferry pardon je veux être là
qu'à niamey c est de tel aviv où
est-elle à vivre je dirais les deux et
lm à vivre oui bien sûr à mon avis c'est
même la seule chose qu'on doive en faire
c'est de la vivre et du coup si on le
prend comme ça oui elle est laide aviv
non pas au sens où ce serait une
béquille ou une thérapeutique mais au
sens où elle élargit la vue la lucidité
et que je crois que un peu pour le coup
comme dans la psychanalyse la lucidité
est quand même toujours préférable à
l'illusion moi je dirais qu'on n'a pas
le temps d'apprendre à vivre
donc de ce point de vue là elle est
vaine mais en revanche la philosophie
est un honnête divertissement comme
disait montaigne
en tout cas j'espère que comme vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure pour votre
rencontre que ce soir pour vous ça aura
été une rencontre pour nous en a été une
et je rappelle vos de livres luc ferry
apprendre à vivre et frédéric schiffter
le philosophe sans qualités chez
flammarion
apprendre à vivre était chez plon voilà
messieurs j'espère que de cette
rencontre
ceux qui nous écoutent vont avoir envie
un peu de parfois retourné à la
philosophie ce qui était mon cas et j'ai
ap
gillet faire et beaucoup de plaisir dans
vos yeux s'ouvrent à vous
[Musique]